here at wired.com we believe in hard
science but we also love kitties so to
feed both obsessions we got our paws on
some Purina kitten chow to find out
what's inside now since our furry
friends are obligate carnivores it means
they don't really need plants in their
diet but they can digest soy flour a
protein with more amino acids than an
equivalent quantity of beef still
there's no pussyfooting around the fact
Mouse's prefer real meat even ground up
byproducts like roly-poly fish heads or
chicken necks feet and the occasional
feather young animal fat is also
included as a source of arachidonic acid
their healthy skin and proper wound
healing when kitties get careless
but while curiosity may kill the
occasional cat heart failure is far more
common so Purina adds taurine to
strengthen cardiovascular function while
preventing retinal degeneration later in
life a pint-sized puss likewise needs
copper sulphate to grow connective
tissue ferrous Sol click to prevent
anemia and zinc sulphate to ensure baby
Tom's have well-developed testes at
least till it's time for a certain
fateful trip to the veterinarian and
finally to keep feline coats perfectly
sleek and full
there's biotin the same vitamin found in
expensive human hair conditioners but
they're worth it good kitty
feeling wired yet subscribe